Dorian gave coastal South Carolina a
beating yesterday and this morning
Charleston is starting to survey the
damage there Dorian's I passed within 55
miles bringing heavy rain and wind gusts
of up to more than 70 miles an hour
Jamie yuccas is in Charleston Jamie what
are you seeing out there right now we're
in historic downtown Charleston and what
I'm seeing is that these streets
yesterday during flash flooding were
covered with water now you just see the
remnants of it today that's the good
news the bad news is all the debris in
this area you see trees like this there
are limbs all throughout the area on
roadways so people are having to clean
that up the other problem is a number of
street signs and utility poles are
either bent or in the roadway so workers
are going to be working to get those
back up before cleanup is completed I
can tell you that there was so much rain
yesterday came down very very hard in
video you can see a lot of the flooding
that ended up occurring in parking lots
on streets it inundated seven inches of
rain so cities are using pumps to try to
get the water out a lot of people had
sandbags surrounding their homes at
certain points in time trying to keep
that water out they did a pretty good
job it wasn't as bad as people thought
it was going to be winds also a big
problem we saw gusts in this area up to
70 miles per hour that's why you had
those trees those utility poles and
power lines come down just to the north
of here there were a number of tornadoes
that happened in Little River and in
Myrtle Beach knocking homes the governor
though has lifted mandatory evacuations
in three counties the only problem will
be if they come back they are going to
have to deal with debris a lot of people
here also still without power about a
hundred and forty thousand Tony alright
Jamie the cleanup begins